vous avez sûrement déjà vu des images de
guerre à la télé vous savez ces images
de guerre surtout dans les pays
africains
je vous conseille dire et penser ça vous
permettra de comprendre mon histoire
j'ai rencontré les bourreaux de ma
famille
et cette rencontre qui devait être une
occasion de vengeance ou moins m'a
permis de passer de l'obscurité à la
lumière d isolement à l'ouverture et de
la haine à l'amour en 2011
je décide de partir en côte d'ivoire
pays originaire de mes parents
pour voir le reste les membres de ma
famille car suite à la guerre
j'ai perdu 19 personnes dix-neuf
personnes de ma famille
dix-neuf personnes assassinées dans des
conditions terribles
cette situation m'a bouleversée et j'y
allais pour me venger mais venger de ses
bourreaux qui ont exterminé une grande
partie de l'ouest et la côte d'ivoire
d'où sont originaires mes parents ces
atrocités qui ont été commises sont sans
précédent les vieillards d'un jeune est
gorgée d'un jeune fille violée et je
tenais à vous préciser que le viol est
devenu désormais une arme redoutable de
guerre dans les pays africains
parce que les jeunes filles qui sait
pour viol et si elle ne meurt pas par la
suite sont rejetés par leur famille
parce que souillé par cet acte elles
deviennent donc la honte du village des
enfants de bas âge et des bébés égorgé
parce que en afrique dans certains
peuples
il ya des dogmes selon lesquelles
lorsqu'on part en guerre et qu'on
utilise des potions magiques à base de
sang frais de deux bébés et des organes
génitaux
on devient plus fort et on devient
vulnérable au bal des ddd fusil
et ces barbares se nourrissaient 17
dogme pour détruire des vies détruites
des populations
c'est dans ce contexte que je décide de
partir en côte d'ivoire j'y arrivais
mardi soir après six heures de vol
un vol qui a été très perturbée comme si
ce vol récente et la colère que j'avais
en moi à l'aéroport dès que je descends
de l'avion
une seule envie mais hanté partir à 600
km de la capitale parti à 600 km
d'abidjan rejoindre ma famille qui se
trouvait tout à fait à l'ouest
mon oncle donc qui vient me chercher à
l'aéroport lui-même ancien reibel en
pardon ancien ministre et ancien otage
de ses reibel me convainc de passer
quelques jours avec lui à la capitale
avant de continuer ma route
cela m'a été bénéfique parce que ça m'a
permis de comprendre les souffrances
qu'il endure et danser quand on appelait
des camps de la mort parce que c'est des
camps qui sont organisées par ces
barbares dans lesquelles on les ressort
t'ai jamais indemne soit on y laisser sa
vie ou son lit ressortez avec un
handicap et chez mon oncle donc à
abidjan j'ai aussi rencontré un cousin
qui est resté très longtemps dans ces
camps et qui m'expliquait comment ces
guerriers utilisaient les libyens
utilisaient ces jeunes filles qu'il
mettait dans ces camps qu'ils violaient
à volonté je vous épargne les détails il
on faisait ce qu'il voulait et quand une
belle fille essayait de série b les
ailes étaient humiliés de façon atroce
et ces jeunes qui avaient l'âge donc de
mon cousin était attaché aux poteaux
et là je ne l'écris apprennent à attirer
sur eux tous ces récits ne faisaient que
amplifié ma colère
quelques jours après être resté chez
montrent donc je décide de partir dans
les terres monte avait très peur parce
qu'il savait les agissements des serres
est belle surtout face aux femmes
je tenais juste à vous rappeler que mon
oncle est juste a été dans ces camps
parce que il était ancien ministre du
gouvernement que ces nouveaux barbares
avait décidé de changer
ils avaient été dépouillés de
pratiquement tous ses biens et il est
resté en vie parce que sa femme qui a
une femme formidable a pu faire
intervenir c'est un président pour le
libérer dès c'est quand il avait très
peur pour moi sachant mon tempérament
ils voulaient pas me laisser y aller il
savait qu'il peux pas m'empêcher parce
que j'avais décidé de le faire
et j'allais le faire jusqu'au bout
j'étais là aussi à vous préciser que je
suis petite fille de propriété à
therrien donc de l'ouest de la côte
d'ivoire et donc nous avons beaucoup de
terre et mes grands parents sont des
très grands agriculteurs donc la
richesse de la côte d'ivoire et est lié
à l'agriculture donc on a des terres et
mes grands parents sont des très grands
producteurs de café cacao hévéa et tout
ce qui s'ensuit donc l'héritage de mon
oncle qui a été volé donc passées les
belles était un héritage qu'il avait
acquis de ses parents donc un héritage
on va dire légal monde décide donc alors
de me faire accompagner par par quatre
gardes du corps et de 4,4 et sachez que
600 km en afrique c'est pas 600 km
bordeaux paris 1 parce que
l'état des routes bonjour on avait aussi
100 km on avait environ 10 ou 12 heures
à faire malgré la puissance des
véhicules en route
c'était la désolation des véhicules
calcinés bord des toutous toute la route
des impacts de balles partout des
villages rasés
cette route que j'avais depuis mon
enfance l'habitude de pratiquer parce
que tous les week-ends on allait au
village je ne les connaissais pas je le
connaissais plus ce paysage tout était
tout était désolation je me retrouvais
plus jamais j'avais perdu mes repères et
tout au long de la route il y avait des
barrages de contrôle que j'avais pas
connu auparavant
après environ 11 heures de route
un des gars du corps maintenant ce qu'on
l'a 20 km du village de mes parents et
qu'on arrivait au plus grand barrage de
contrôle
le barrage du chef de guerre c'est lui
là que je voudrais rencontrer les
véhicules s'immobilisent et je vois de
monsieur veniez dans ma direction qui
était armé des amulettes partout sur le
corps à cet instant je ne sais plus
quelle émotion m'anime
je ne sais plus où je suis je ne sais
plus ce que je fais parce que c'était
plus fort que moi
à cet instant je suis perdu je jeûnais
discerne plus rien comment comment agit
qu'est ce qu'est ce que je vais faire
face à cette colère est face à des
hommes armés comment comment je vais
agir je je je ne peux pas vous le dire
il arrive à notre niveau il nous demande
de descendre du véhicule
je refuse d'obtempérer
il réitère je refuse à nouveau à cette
instance g200 la tension qui monte
les gars du coin autour de moi le
chauffeur il s'est dit mais qu'est ce
qu'elle va nous fait encore celle là est
un de ces de ces barbares dit en patois
malheureusement que je comprends pour
lui c'est qui cette petite dame qui
osent refuser d'exécuter nos ordres
cette dame qui habillés à l'occidentale
mais de façon vulgaire de façon alors
son chef lui dit leur dis j'arrive à cet
instant là j'ai juste eu le réflexe
d'ouvrir la portière de la voiture que
j'ai commencé à vomir mais vomi toute là
toute la haine qui était en moi toute la
colère parce que c'était pas de la haine
j'ai pas de haine en moi toute la colère
qui était en moi a commencé a ressorti
au point des les éclabousser j'ai tout
sorti parce que j'en avais besoin je ne
savais pas comment agi c'était ma façon
à moi des véhicules et mon message
j'ai tout sorti et j'ai vu que cette
situation les avaient perturbé parce
qu'ils savaient plus quoi faire ils
savaient ils savaient pas ils me
regardaient il ya ben sans réaction
quand j'ai pu me soulager je me suis
raide ray c'est vers le chef de guerre
il y avait juste un mot qui m'est revenu
en tête juste je lui a demandé pourquoi
pourquoi toute cette haine
pourquoi toute cette destruction
pourquoi
il est resté sans rien dire j'espère que
ces quelques moments de silence pendant
ces quelques moments de silence il
entendait les cris les pleurs la
souffrance le rejet de tous ces
innocents tués après ce moment de
silence
il demande à ses subordonnés de se
retirer
et là on passe à la séquence confession
ils m'expliquent qu'ils n'étaient pas
guerrier à la base il est venu d'un pays
voisin
il a été recruté dans le pays voisin
justement on lui a promis donc 300 euros
équivalente 300 euros par mois et un
poste dans l'armée après la guerre qui
devait durer environ trois mois
et là il arrive donc en côte d'ivoire il
se retrouve chef de guerre
il a sous son autorité 500 jeunes qui
n'ont pas été après jeu n'ont pas été
formés pour utiliser les armes de guerre
imaginez il ne sait plus quoi faire
parce que on est là nos lits sont pas
nourris
donc ils étaient obligés d'attaquer les
villageois de le prendre tous leurs
biens pour pouvoir se nourrir et pour
pouvoir nourrir leurs familles restées
au pays pendant environ je ne sais plus
10 à 15 minutes
il m'a raconté sa vie il est venu là
parce qu'il voulait que ses enfants
soient scolarisés et 300 euros
la base c'est c'est le salaire d'un
cadre et donc ils avaient besoin de cet
argent là pour pouvoir scolariser ses
enfants s'occuper de sa famille est là
quelque chose se passe en moi
- qui au départ était parti me venger je
passe de la femme qui veut se venger à
la femme a pesé à l'ecoute et cet
individu que je ne connaissais pas et
qui est le bourreau de ma famille je les
écoute avec attention et je ne sais pas
pourquoi je crois assez dire je suis
j'avais l'impression qu'ils manipulaient
mais en même temps j'avais confiance en
ce qu'il disait et je ne savais pas je
l'écoutais je regardais ses gestes et
quand il a fini de se confesser je lui
ai demandé est ce que si aujourd'hui je
lui remettais ce kit ce dont ils avaient
besoin pour repartir éviter de tuer est
ce que il repartirait ch lui donc il me
confirme que c'est la seule chose qu'ils
attendaient ils voulaient reparti chez
lui mais de façon discrète parce que
s'il s'est fait attraper par c'est le
cutter on le tuerait pas si c'est la
considérer comme un traître
alors je me suis dit voilà est-ce que là
il n'y a pas un effet les cochers parce
que moment qui passe et la femme vend
giresse on va dire je deviens une femme
compatissante
est-ce que cet individu là n'est pas
autant de victimes que ma famille parce
que finalement c'est ça il arrive dans
un pays qui ne connaît pas il devient
chef de guerre parce que voilà et et là
je il a autant victimes je comprends
qu'il ait autant de victimes que que ma
famille
donc je me concerne avec avec les gardes
du corps et je décide de lui donner une
enveloppe à une seule condition à
condition qu'il accepte de reparti chez
lui et qu'il arrête de tuer
donc entre ce chef de guerre et moi il
ya eu un deal qui c'est qui ce qui s'est
passé et ça a été quelque chose pour moi
de formidables parce que si comme il le
dit il avait besoin de cet argent pour
scolariser ses enfants
je me suis dit s'il avait cette chance
peut-être d'être instruits d'aller à
l'école il serait pas là j'ai commencé à
me poser des questions l'instruction est
une nécessité
on en a besoin avant 2 avant de terminer
mon propos j'aimerais j'aimerais vous
dis ceci toi qui m'écoutent je voudrais
te dit ceci c'est vrai j'ai perdu 19
membres de ma famille 19
ça n'a pas été facile j'ai porté le
deuil pendant longtemps cependant y at
il pas plus de 19 personnes sur cette
terre qui ont besoin de mon âme au qui
ont besoin de mon affection
y at il pas plus de 19 personnes sur
cette terre qui ont besoin de ma
compassion
forte de cette idée je m'engage apaisée
et plus que jamais déterminées à
exécuter ma mission celle d'être le
pilier du pardon et de la réconciliation
partout où je sers et permettre aux gens
de nos peuples de mieux vivre ensemble
désormais je sais que nous ne pouvons
être prouvées au delà de nos forces car
une petite lumière brille toujours au
fond de notre coeur qui nous rend plus
forts que les épreuves de la vie
un seul mot guide aujourd'hui ma vie
l'amour je vous remercie